this chapter has to be one of the
craziest chapters ever we've been
waiting for this for so long and here we
got Elder Saturn finally stepping into
action The Secret of his power is
finally revealed and we finally get to
see how much of a threat the five Elders
actually are not to mention gear five
Luffy versus kizaru's shocking ending
and more so make sure to stay tuned for
this historic chapter CH the py king
within and smash that like button if you
enjoyed these chapter reviews and want
to keep them coming make this the video
you join the knock up by subscribing and
hitting that notific ification Bell so
you don't miss future one piece videos
and updates with just one click of that
button you can help us reach our insane
dream of 2 million subscribers on
YouTube thank you and without further
Ado let's jump into It spoilers and all
so this chapter is called Warrior God of
Science and defense Saint J Garcia
Saturn which makes sense as I already
mentioned he is the craziest thing about
this chapter which is saying a lot with
the gear five Luffy and kizaru climax
stuff going on also a cool note we got
is that the color spread this time
around is promoting a monsters anime
Special all shimoi family members so a
kind of Zoro family tree is featured
with ryuma zombie ryuma Zoro quina
kosaburo yasui and great uncle of Zoro
ushimaru and onimaru as a Zoro and
anything Zoro related Fanboy I love that
they featured these characters and I'm
looking forward to the monster special
anime which if it's like oda's monsters
one shot will feature sword God and Zoro
ancestor Ruma in his youth but onto the
chapter itself which starts with all paf
istas obeying atlas's order and
attacking the Marines so that looks good
but it seems like the pacifistas just
keep switching back and forth as we're
about to see for now we follow Bonnie
and she's fighting the Marines too glad
to see her getting so much attention
this AR she's definitely one of my
favorite Supernova she uses a new attack
which is always hype and it's called nde
or near-death experience she fires a gun
at Marines and they hallucinate with
their own deaths it seems like an
interesting extension of her ability to
make people age up or down and I'm
wondering if it's a clue to a kind of
Awakening of this aging paramia fruit
because it doesn't seem to usually work
this way but perhaps that would be too
much Awakening at once cuz you'll see
why my mind is on devil fruit Awakening
during this chapter soon enough after
that Bonnie faces two Vice Admirals now
I don't know about you but I just can't
take Vice Admirals too seriously except
GARP of course still these two succeed
in giving Bonnie trouble the one with
the long chin and mustache wields a long
staff with a huge seashell at the tip
honestly a pretty cool sounding weapon
to use against devil fruit users from
the sound it because obviously their
weakness is the sea but we'll wait and
see how it actually works and what kind
of effect it has the other vice admiral
is the old lady Blu grass and she ate
the noty Noy no meat always fun to see
new devil fruit powers in action and
this one is quite interesting we're told
it allows her to ride and control
everything she rides so in this case
Bluegrass is riding one of the
pacifistas so Bonnie can't do anything
against her although it's sort of
anticlimactic for a worst Generations
pirate and a supernova to not be able to
do anything against two Vice Admirals
but throwing a pacifist that looks like
her father and given her traumatized
experience associated with that I guess
you can see why Sanji a non worse
generation's pirate Captain needs to
come in and save her he jumps down the
Vega tank 8 and does just that saving
Bonnie just in time although to be fair
I think it's not surprising at this
point for us to have our straw head Yono
commanders stronger than Supernova
captains in any case anyways this is
where things get not just crazy but
creepy too you'll know what I mean at a
magic circle with a five-point star and
a number five symbol suddenly appears in
the middle of Egghead Island along with
fire and black lightning explosions and
of course those black lightning
explosions have me wondering if those
could be associated with hockey as well
because next we see Saturn clearly the
lower part of his body is a spider like
black Maria with a flame shaped pattern
Saturn's beard and hair become like
flowing clouds he too has a black cloud
wrap over his neck like Luchi and Kaku
Luffy has a similar thing just white so
as I speculated even before I knew that
this would happen in this chapter in my
recent all 14 awakened devil fruits in
one piece video this seems to be a sign
of an awakened Zone user specifically
one who doesn't lose their personality
after Awakening like the jail beasts P.S
I also think that having strong
willpower a common theme in one piece is
a factor in not losing your personality
after Zone Awakening so yes if I had to
bet on it I'd guess this is an awakened
mythical Zone fruit but I wonder how
they'll explain the magic circle aspect
of this transformation anyways Saturn's
face looks human but Saturn's nose is
more wide and he has two big horns in
his hat even the spoilers say it seems
like he's using his hybrid awakened form
but it's not confirmed in this chapter
we're told Saturn looks like an USI Oni
or guki which is a yo-kai from Western
Japanese folklore you just got to Google
usion to see how creepy this Yokai is
and it looks like Oda timed this reveal
power perfectly given that Halloween is
fast approaching another case for this
being his fruits inspiration is the
parallel that usion generally appear on
beaches and attack people who walk there
while now the Elder is coming from the
sea to attack the people on this island
we then jump to the equally hype Luffy
versus kizaru fight and it's just crazy
what happens next Luffy and kizaru are
both panting kizaru straight up says he
can't stay fighting or else he won't
complete his mission now I said last
time that kizu was running cuz he
couldn't just beat Luffy and some people
were saying nah it's not that he's just
prioritizing his mission but here again
we have him needing to run he's even
panting and I know I've been saying
Luffy can beat kizaru but to see kizaru
acting like this is still crazy even to
me he literally cannot overcome Luffy
he's exhausted and needs to find a way
to escape Now isn't that just awesome to
even see that an admiral like kizu
cannot no matter how much he wants to
bulldoze over our boy Luffy it's so cool
to see how far Luffy has come so once
again kizaru flies away with super speed
to attack Vega Punk kizaru shoots a
laser at Vega tank 8 but it misses
however still the laser does do damage
and it destroys the Cloud Road making
Vega tank 8 fall to the ground and now
these two crazy events of the chapter
intersect as suddenly Saturn's voice can
be heard all over Egghead Island Saturn
says pacifistas stop end quote so it was
a short-lived Victory having the
pacifistas on our side for a few panels
furthermore we're given a very
interesting detail we're told all strong
characters on the island Luffy kizaru
Zoro Luchi Sanji jimbe the vice Admirals
and so on suddenly stop because they
feel an unusual Aura that's very hyped
to hear like when Luffy could sense
chs's hockey at wano although the term
unusual also makes it seem like it could
just be this evil creepy Aura as well
but back to Luffy versus kizaru and
Luffy has caught up kizaru asks Luffy
and it almost sounds like he's hoping
for this and I quote that form is
already at its limit right end quote
Luffy though shows that it's not quite
and hits kizaru with a new attack called
gugu No star gun AKA gum gum white star
gun it's like the crazy thing he did
against kaido that I always talk about
when his punch went through kaido's face
this one goes through kizaru's face but
it seems worse this time because the
attack creates many Star effects so good
to see Luffy's devil fruit affecting the
tired kizaru hopefully that means
kizaru's time is numbered against Luffy
at least kizaru even says oh this is bad
and you love to hear something like that
and then both Luffy and kizaru fall to
the ground together so it seems like
that might be the conclusion to the
kizaru and Luffy fight kizaru might be
out of commission for a while from the
looks of these spoilers and then Saturn
says I quote NAA end quote noticing
Luffy falling Luffy turns to Old Man
form when he falls to the ground now
we'll see how Oda chooses to handle this
but we know from experience that Luffy
could right away return to his gear five
form against kaido and since he should
be more experienced now I don't think
it's crazy to think that he can do it at
least one more time now but the crazier
question is will he take on this elder
after kizaru an insane backto back or
will his crew somehow manage to save him
and Escape without the need for Luffy to
fight again let me know your thoughts in
the comments either way great to see
Luffy doing this to Admiral kizaru who
felt so untouchable for so long just
remember how crazy strong and
Untouchable he seen back in the day
compared to our guys in the final double
page of the chapter Saturn is facing
Bonnie Sanji Vega Punk and Frankie now
with the way the fandom has been hyping
up the elders it's hard to believe that
Sanji can do much against him but that's
the beauty of this we'll get to truly
see the extent of Saturn's head-to-head
power do you think Saturn would easily
best even kizaru or now that Luffy
seemingly took care of kizaru will the
others be able to handle Saturn one way
or another then Bonnie remembers
something from her past but we don't
know who are the people that say the
words Bonnie remembers Bonnie's memories
go like this and I quote I gave the
order Vega Punk there must be no
consciousness remaining but if you do
that Kuma will dot dot dot end quote
after that Bonnie jumps and stabs
Saturn's chest with a sword seemingly
knowing he is one of the people to blame
for everything some blood flows from
Saturn's chest and that is the end of
the chapter with thankfully no break
next week Imagine Bonnie just one shot
Saturn right here but all aside cannot
wait to see what Saturn is capable of in
an actual fight how far beyond Sanji
level do you think this awakened monster
could be and I didn't know this would
happen but now the timing seems perfect
if this new Awakening has pequ your
interest in Awakenings then you won't
want to miss my recent video on all 14
awaken devil through users and their
powers explained link on screen right
now like And subscribe to help us
achieve our insane goal of two million
nakama members on YouTube and I'll see
you in the next one